bonjour je me nomme bruno marché donc je
j'ai 57 ans je suis une personne portant
un handicap c'est à dire que les
problèmes
colonne vertébrale sans plus puisque je
suis très mobiles pour métier et
conseiller assistant commercial plutôt
chargé clientèle vu mes expériences
passées dans la comptabilité donc j'ai
peu à même aujourd'hui me dire que je
suis un assistant commercial préparer et
secondaires de commercial je dispose
d'un véhicule comme vous déplacer je
recherche plutôt dans la région ouest
donc je suis optimiste
j'ai beaucoup de rigueur dans le travail
donc je serais heureux d'apporter mon
expérience au sein de votre entreprise
merci